as you can see on my face on Monday
night I was attacked from behind by a
racist new research by the group hug not
haters found that those with far-right
views are getting younger and more
violent three political extremes of sort
to weaponize my attack to serve their
own ideological Dogma on the far left
anti-racists are victim-blaming by
implying that my centrist views somehow
legitimize right-wing hate on the
far-right some are claiming that this
was a hoax meanwhile Islamists are
openly celebrating my attack what unites
these three extremes is their hatred for
people whose mere existence disrupts
each of their narratives I do not hate
my cowardly attacker and I do not wish
to blame one political persuasion over
another for the general rise in bigotry
in my life I've been attacked by people
from all three of these extremes but
attacks like this mustn't be used to
silence political disagreement that's
precisely what the attackers want so let
us proceed with one principle in mind no
idea is above scrutiny just as no person
is beneath dignity now just a warning
this debate may contain language that
some viewers may find offensive well
first of all thank you for coming to
work today it's so brave considering
that this attack only happened a couple
of days ago and I think everything that
you've just said is so honorable and
perhaps a lot of people wouldn't take
that view if they were in your shoes why
do you think it's important for us not
to hate but to look at ways of finding
solutions well I mean I think first of
all I'd say I've already been down the
path of hate when I was younger so
unlike a lot of people perhaps I just
have that benefit of knowing what that's
like and and the fact that it leads to
nothing good and that was again because
I was as I was growing up in a six are
subject to extremely violent racist
abuse and attacks but in those days it
was with hammers and knives and again in
those days I was saved by people in
particular one incident that we've
spoken about on this show a former a
former servicemen who intervened in fact
he texted me just this morning about
this recent attack and
and said he wishes he was there again to
to try and help partner said you've
already done enough in my life but I
think because I've already been down
that path mm-hmm I have the benefit of
hindsight in knowing that harboring
hatred and blaming a group of people for
the actions of a callous individual
isn't the way to go and most of the
people that helped me on Monday evening
were also white non-muslims and they
they really kept me sane and the love
they they showed immediately after the
hatred that was that was sown by the
racist I think that kept me sane Wow Wow
do you think it was haven't interesting
them to do you think it was aimed at you
as an individual or you because of your
voice
no I it was uh I don't think didn't
suspect he didn't know who I was
he held racist abuse at me as he hit me
self in [ __ ] and it's because I asked
him not to be racist to another family
who were East Asian and that's where he
was racially abusing another family you
intervened and then he attacked you I he
said he would attack me first so what I
did is I pulled my phone out to try and
record him because I thought he was
about to attack me and I thought that
might deter him and as I held my phone
up he knocked it out of my hand and the
phone fell and all of these cards spill
everywhere and uh and then I think this
chap that looked to me like he was
homeless he ran towards my phone so I
thought I was about to get robbed and so
I bent down spit my phone up not
suspecting this guy was gonna show a
complete and utter lack of decency and
as I bent down to pick my phone up from
behind and it was just a straight racist
attack
nothing it does show that unfortunately
in this country and all around the world
there are a certain type of people who
just find it acceptable to ever go to
somebody because they got what they want
because they're different color their
sexuality and it absolutely grates me
because it's it's bullying for one and I
can't stand bullies but what that games
have done to you it's just completely
inexcusable
you know it's why he's right if you even
to turn down you know he's only attacked
you once you're not fight so he's a taxi
with a cheap shot after saying something
racist it just is that I've got
mixed-race grandchildren and I actually
fear for them because I do believe
you're right it is picking up in some
areas this racism thing and it's just
it's not on it means didn't
to be stamped on Anna needs to be
extinguished yes thank you possible
because people who are vulnerable to
that kind of influence are more likely
to listen to your words just like
Muslims who are vulnerable to extremism
we know there's two types of people in
as well to forget about the color of
your skin what you like what you like
sexually and all the rest of it all
right there's two types of people in
this world there's write-ins and as
romans and you know which side of the
fence you're on because you know what's
right near that was wrong and if you
were wrong and you were running you're
not I mean it's just I'd be fascinated
if the police catch the person to this
because I like you and I also respect
you and I'm also in a position where
I've never been punched in the face
because of what I look like or abused
because of what I look like
and I'm fascinated as to what goes
through the head of somebody who would
even think that that would be okay on
any level and I'll be fascinated if the
police caught this person who did this
to you for you to actually have a
conversation with the person what goes
through your head to even think it's
okay to hit somebody you based on what
they look like so I like to practice
what I preach and on this show before
I've advocated for my belief in
restorative justice and shorter prison
sentence I would like for this man you
talked to I hope he's listening I don't
think prison is gonna help him in fact
you probably get beaten up in prison
because prisons run by gangs who are
from ethnic minorities and they probably
don't want to take revenge and I don't
wish that upon prisons run by various
gangster fairies but a lot of Muslim
gangs are getting really strong in
prison so what would you say to him even
if the present issue with this person I
would like to see him face to face I
can't stop the fact that criminal
justice system has to deliver justice
but I would like to sit down with him
and have a conversation with him and
trying to understand the impact young
man I think the conversations fine but
it needs to be backed up with some stiff
punishment I don't believe you can
tickle anybody on any situation you've
got it you gotta give him a proper I
mean we've all known periods where there
was racial intolerance and racial
violence in this country
is he getting worse again it is and can
I just bring in some stats on that this
is shocking in terms of actual religious
hate crime at 2016 to 2017 there were
5,000 949
reported cases 2017 to 2018 there were
8,000 336 that's an increase of almost
40% in just a year and wait for this 52%
of all offenses were aimed at Muslims so
something's going on in the country you
look at the predictions for the European
elections across Europe and I think the
figures show that they the far right
which last time got 10% of the vote they
now expect to get 14% of the vote you
know the problem is that I grew up with
this stuff and I do feel like it's
coming back around again and you can't
explain like I was walking through East
London with my father yesterday I spent
the day with my father and my
two-year-old son just as I take a bit of
downtime and it's emotionally it's very
difficult because in East London there's
a lot of people who look like me and I
felt safe whenever I saw somebody looked
like me and felt felt felt like I was
looking over my shoulder to see if there
any white person was gonna attack me and
that's an emotional response to trauma
but that's how I used to feel when I was
15 years old a daily basis on a daily
basis because we were hunted in what
they used to call [ __ ] bashing and
that's what's happened to me I was [ __ ]
bashed on Monday evening right and so it
is unfortunate because exactly what the
extremists want to create is they want
our communities to divide they want us
to stop trusting each other and and they
want us to stop having the the liberty
to debate ideas that we may disagree on
that's exactly what they want so clear
and the integration we've worked so hard
to create
and all these years we've been working
and so that's why I focused on in my
introduction on the fact that we mustn't
let this stop political debate brexit or
remain the debate has to continue
because actually if we then use this and
weaponized instrumentalize it to say
well that's why you can't be i'm remain
right but if you can't be brexit well
actually that's what they want they want
us to shut debate down and have only one
opinion you know and only one opinion is
acceptable and everything else there's
not the trouble that I mention exactly
the point Phil made there's some
goodness imbalance yeah you know and
actually debate do you mate amongst the
bad news is quite difficult yeah well
that's what Andrus well I mean that's
why you know there that's why it's very
important for us to say that actually
people there are there are bad people in
every faction we know that there's
violence among the far
and hansi Semites and racists we know
there's violence and racism on the far
right clearly with the other the other
third extreme Muslims we know this
violence there so it's not about one
political faction or another it's about
good human beings are bad humans just
take comfort in the fact that you are
probably ten times the man that that
person is you are you are someone that I
respect enormous Lee and I dread to
think the state of the person that did
that to you and we thank you for coming
on today to talk about it because in
doing so you will have helped so many
people who perhaps have been in similar
situations to yourself